Ever wondered
how wildlife crews
managed to capture
the perfect shot right
in the heart of the action?
Check out the behind
the scenes to see
the great lengths
that the crew went
to to film "Hostile Planet."
MATT RICHARDS: Rock
copper penguins
live in cold, quiet
often brutal conditions.
It's a pretty tough
location to get to.
It's very remote.
It's quite near Antarctica.
We left about a month,
so it was a long trip.
And so we really got
to spend a lot of time
with those penguins.
ANTHONY PYPER: The
best thing for us
is to be noticed by the
species we're filming
and get them completely
used to us being there
so we're just part
of the furniture.
MATT RICHARDS: We were filming
where the penguins were
coming onto shore, essentially
it was a sort of boulder field.
It's covered in a thin film of
guano, which is fine when it's
dry but the second you get
any moisture it essentially
becomes like walking on ice.
PETE CAYLISS: It's sunset here
on New Islands in the Falklands
and I've just been
waiting for penguins
to return from the sea.
The bit I'm actually trying
to film at the moment
is where they explode from
the water onto the dry land.
And to do this, I'm using
a high speed filming rig.
I want to time it exactly right.
And you get barely
any warning at all.
[chirping]
MATT RICHARDS: What's
on the agenda today?
Today we are taking
the giant homemade crane
right down to the penguins.
It's just what we
call a pole cam,
but a sort of enormous
version of that.
Really, the whole
point of the crane
is to have a camera at the
end and us as far as possible.
So here's the business
end of the crane.
So far it looks good,
so we'll give it a go.
[music playing]
Ultimately, we were
trying to capture
how difficult it was for a
penguin to feed its chicks.
We wanted to see how they coped
in really hostile conditions.
And we got lucky because
we got the biggest
storm in the Falklands that
they'd had for 30 years.
It was pretty scary, actually.
So the storm has kicked
in and the penguins
are still coming in.
Those 80 mile an hour winds,
the waves were getting bigger.
Bit too windy for the drone?
It's a bit windy.
We didn't know how
far these waves were
going to come up the shore.
We were playing this fine
gambling game where you
definitely wanted to be safe
but you wanted to try and get
that immersive feel of
what it's like to be
a penguin coming in a storm.
The thing that really stands
out is how well these animals
can cope with some of the
most hostile conditions you
can imagine.
Every time you come back from a
shift you have fresh admiration
for these amazing animals.
[music playing]